wenn wir jetzt sagen müssten wir von uns
sich für mehr etwas besonderes hält weiß
überhaupt nicht ich war immer muss ich
so du das ist das coole hast du wenn du
das macht man so einfach ja ich weiss
man macht das so aber ich muss das erst
über das lustige ist dass mir
aufgefallen ist dass ich selbst fast nur
mit dir machen
robert verleiht das buch heißt
erwachsenen sprache die grundthese
dieses buches ist dass es von
erwachsenen leuten gar nicht mehr
erwartet wird dass sie sich wie
erwachsene benehmen und was heißt dass
sich wie ein erwachsener zu das ist die
große frage einmal quasi distanz zur
welt dachte eigentlich dass das distanz
zur welt humor sei das ist der zweite
punkt ist tanz zu sich selbst abstand zu
sich selbst ein bisschen selbstironie
gehört für einen fall auch zum
erwachsensein
das ist meins elfi gesehen ja genau das
bringt mich wunderbarer weise zu diesem
titel andreas rackwitz zur zeit viel
diskutiert jeder hat das gefühl er trägt
in sich irgend einen speziellen
wesenskern dem man unbedingt entfalten
und kuratieren und pflegen muss das hat
natürlich die kehrseite dass der
solidaritätsgedanke zum beispiel den
hintergrund tritt
der screen wird schon dunkel weil du so
lange brauchen ich lächele doch also
mehr leichen geht nicht mit zehn meinst
du ehrlich gesagt bin ich froh dass du
mir erklärt was drinsteht zwei dies gilt
für die kollaborationen und projekt in
der arbeits und politischen welt ja die
einheiten bestehen weiter versuchen von
der massenkultur und der mainstream
politik weit entfernt so reden wir alle
tage meine damen und herren jeder hält
sich auch für was besonderes wir sind
beide gar nichts
nein wir sind beide gar nichts
besonderes im grunde schrecklich
könntest du die bitte nach erlöschen ich
bin da eher ein bisschen skeptisch